if this Market existed when I was 15
years old I would have never graduated
high school
no shot in [__] hell put the flag in
the ground I'll show you my [__]
[__] report card it's somewhere here
zero chance so to your point I can't
even imagine what you and others are
going to be doing over the next couple
years to make it even less friction
Vayner nation very exciting for me to be
putting out this podcast because there's
like a hundred things that are going to
bring value to everybody in this podcast
first even how it happened we got
incredible company to talk to you about
the sports car National is coming up go
Google the national sports card
convention go get a ticket come by be
friends has a big activation I'll be
there all week I'm impossible to find
because I'm usually in my office and
traveling and this is always one of the
ways to get a quick selfie or a quick
conversation so I'll be there we're
going to talk about mascot we'll get
into that in a minute we're gonna talk
about the overall Card Market which I
haven't done in a while
which is really fun for me because I've
been quietly buying as Rip snows I
bought two very significant Aaron
Rodgers rookie cards which is also
exciting because training campus started
and boy am I more excited than I
realized I've got a lot going on in my
life these days so I've been a little
more distracted than my normal insanity
but like the Jets reported the camp and
I'm all fired up so this should be a
super fun episode especially for a lot
of you are starting to actually collect
v-friends collectible cards which is
like a hole to do which we'll probably
touch on for a few minutes since we got
rips but more importantly why I'm
excited to have masks out here and as it
really explain it we'll go deep into it
up front is
in 2018 when I started first making
sports card content it was not only did
I say huh I think this could be like
sneakers and I think that ended up being
very real I really nailed that I think I
get a lot of credit for that but it was
also like man there's a lot of
opportunity for like Innovation like the
tech in this industry [__] sucks like
and like wait to like Tech comes to this
and over the last four five years I've
seen a lot of good there's a lot more
Tech thank God uh but there's still a
long way to go and I think uh you and
your company represent some of that
stuff so I'm excited about that so we'll
talk about that and we'll talk about
innovating in industries that have
opportunities how you guys and gals
think about that I'll let you introduce
yourself to your story a little bit and
talk about mascot so we'll talk about
innovating the market but then just in
general the card Market's fun like it's
in a fun spot it's kind of like where I
see the nft market being in another year
kind of starting to hit now which is
like normalcy comes in you kind of have
like that high tide of excitement and
the normalcy comes in and the normalcy
of day-to-day card life today is
dramatically better than it was in 2017
and 18. of course it's not on the covet
Highs but it's that and similar to nfts
like I'm watching a lot of people do
open mints at 0.09 Andy like you showed
me an epic one today from our guy and
like like people are still collecting
digital Collectibles it's it's just now
people realizing nft Collectibles are
like trading cards one percent of
trading cards are meant to be insane
Jordan rookie Charizard you know like
real real stuff not everyone and that's
where we're starting to see in nft land
there's still a lot of collectors right
now you got to get over the the decline
and I still think we're six months to a
year of like fully being over that out
of the masses cultural mind and people
starting to come back in and getting
serious so like fun stuff and
alternative collecting we're at the
Forefront of it with befriends trading
cards Envy friends nfts like so I'm
enjoying this and so it's one big
conversation of innovation
in the collectibility world which is
obviously super fun for me because that
has been my life besides that little
thing I did in the Middle with wine I
was in Collectibles and then I've been
in Innovation so Ezra that was a big
frame up to the episode why don't you
tell everybody in the Vayner Nation who
you are what you do and what the
company's about and we could talk about
it rips maybe can jump in and awesome uh
my name is Ezra Levine I'm the CEO of a
new company called mascot and I want to
give Dr James Beckett a little credit
here obviously Dr James Beckett is a big
innovator in the space and so I told him
the name mascot we happen to like the
name mascot we were not thinking
necessarily as an acronym but when I
spoke to Dr James Beckett he said oh
mascot brilliant I said why he goes
because that stands for multi-sales
channel technology and I said you know
what I'm gonna steal that I love it so
mascots it didn't originally but we're
going to go with that I love it I love
it so mascot now we've amended it a
little bit mascot is multi-asset sales
Channel optimization technology which of
course rolls out the tongue beautifully
but essentially what we did is we
created an awesome product and you know
I think to your to your point Innovation
this Collectibles industry has come a
long way but there's so much more to go
so much more to go so mascot essentially
is the easiest and fastest way to manage
your collection and by far the easiest
and fastest way to sell items within
your collection I know you don't do a
lot of selling but I think this will be
very relevant for your audience who does
uh We've integrated this is trying to
get me to sell more ships like I don't
want to sell I like that narrative and I
like that truth but I should probably
all right so uh on part one right so how
to manage your collection so we've
integrated with all the meter the major
Grading Company so PSA back at SGC cgc
uh in tag yep where we essentially have
API feeds and Partnerships directly with
them when you put in one detail of your
items all the data around the populates
you can put in a serial number all the
data populates all the high-res images
populated so you know on your collection
Gary we were testing with Adam we did
250 items just about in about 30 seconds
it's wild it's really fast so really
crazy does Adam have to put in the
serial number of my thing and boom so
three three different ways to do it one
is you can drag and drop images if you
have high-res scans you can just put the
image and it'll read all the data you
can also put in the serial number or if
you have a spreadsheet they're working
off of you can just drag which a lot of
people have exactly so you can upload
what about the spreadsheet what about
when I have it in my pwcc Vault like is
that gonna be easy
yeah so Adam Adam tried it essentially
he took a spreadsheet from Peter good
no I really think this might be crazy
good so kudos to you guys well thank you
and so part part two of what we do uh so
we created again a multi-sales channel
platform so the the selling experience
in Collectibles is downright terrible
right so if you create an eBay listing
it takes a long time yeah you create you
know if you want to sell multiple
platforms you got to create individual
listings it takes time uh what mascot
has done is you can integrate all of
your secondary Market uh platforms right
now eBay my slabs Amazon Shopify you can
see it in a middleware talking to the
nerds in there you've got a middleware
right CRM you know content management
system where you've sat in the middle of
the two most important things right what
is your inventory and how do you sell it
and by creating really strong Tech that
really works well on both sides you have
a value prop to a lot of us yeah look it
is that right do I have a spot on it it
connects your collection to all the
marketplaces in which you want to sell
so you can create essentially one
listing on mascot and it creates
multiple listings all across the
marketplace you know our vision and our
thought is that you know you want to
maximize both as a seller right as a
seller you want really three things you
want to maximize eyeballs so it can sell
the fastest right you want to sell it
you know as quickly as you possibly can
for the highest price and essentially on
your own timeline to get maximum
eyeballs that makes it a lot easier the
technology but also it does a lot of
people who sell multiple platforms they
have you know really big issue which is
if it sells in one holy crap you got to
figure out you know where else it's
listed then you gotta go back and go
into those accounts and remove it before
double sale which could knock down your
reviews I know when you were a kid a lot
of like Facebook Marketplace but then
also on eBay like that must have been
your day-to-day
did you ever have a double Sail by
accident because like the Unlucky timing
or did you see if he's gonna suck at
selling so much that it never really
happens
sold everywhere yeah yeah especially in
the height of that whole cover like I
remember like Terence Davis would have
like a good game for the Raptors I'd buy
like every rookie card on Earth yeah so
Devonte Graham so our technology will
essentially automatically remove all the
other listings so sales and eBay
automatically would you say this is for
like the top 10 20 Elite it's like a
super tool and then for the masses it's
just like a stronger piece of technology
I think anyone who has inventory that
they want to manage or sell it's a great
product we have people who are massive
dealers you know thousands of thousands
of cards huge value with people who have
five cards up there or five items five
complex whatever it is zero free
absolutely free to use them to Partners
so I so we're building a premium model
too so you can have the basic skills and
the basic tools completely free we want
to get as many users as possible
freemium smart uh and then we're
building Advanced features so you wanna
you wanna set algorithmic pricing you
want to do all that great stuff
um which really saves people a lot of
time that maximizes money and maximize
money that will be premium model and all
these other commercial arrangements with
vendors which allow us to really build a
great business AI like the [__] it's
gonna get really wild it's gonna be fun
okay makes sense how long have you guys
been at it so we took over company
called slab folio slab folio has been
around for about a year and a half we
came in I saw this technology actually
at last year's National I saw this and
said here's a product that makes the
industry so much more efficient here's a
product if I clean this up here's a
product that has applications for anyone
in this market whether you're a dealer
whether you're a Marketplace whether
you're a Grading Company whether you're
just an industry participant whether
you're just a collector this has so many
applications for you and that is what
really got me excited so I left
collectible came here we spent the last
three or four months really doing three
things one is cleaning up the UI ux
making it a lot easier to use doing all
the Partnerships we've made the platform
so much faster by doing these deals we
know of direct API feeds the platform's
100 to 200 times faster uh and really
when have you been in this new form I
joined that four months ago meaning I'm
sorry the product look for the people
listening because some you know we have
a lot of card people some might have
looked at it like I don't know when did
it come out as this mascot was rolled
out about I don't know when this is
going to error but you know probably
about a week or two weeks ago so recent
recent but it's a huge Improvement first
taste for everybody that goes on first
taste and what's this.com just to make
sure we get it with mascot.com with with
mascot.com and socials at with mascot
with withe got it okay
now let's Veer off back and we'll come
back to this in a minute what about your
Trading Card Journey yeah I saw you grow
up here New York New York City New York
City city boy city boy proper city boy
proper so I was a big as you are Knicks
fan yep I'm a Giants fan sorry sorry uh
Rangers Yankees so good good so you know
my my collecting Journey I'm sure sorry
that's pretty much everyone how old is
everyone I'm 35. okay 35. so you know I
collected a lot as a kid and were you a
Pokemon because age my brother AJ's 30
what am I 40. uh 8 36 and Pokemon was he
did predominantly cards but there was a
big poke when Pokemon hit you guys were
in a great age I was all sports I I wish
I were Pokemon because you know it has
exploded but I was all sports I was a
product of the junk wax error but I
remember I'm sure you an Asian to the
zoo I used to set up card shops and my
brother wrote on rooms we scored all the
shows uh it was I used to be at summer
camp my parents would send boxes of
cards I was the coolest kid at someone
Camp just because of that for no other
reason and it was awesome it was a great
time and then you know I uh in my career
yeah I got out of it I went to Michigan
for college and came back to New York
worked in finance but you know my dad's
been a big shout out to Aiden Hutchinson
Vayner Sports Go Blue go blue and uh
yeah I was in finance and then I
actually started a minor league football
league and uh it's now the usfl so we
merged into Fox Sports and became the
usfl that's how I met AJ actually for
the first time was through Vayner Sports
and then you know my dad's been a
collector he kept me in the loop on it
and uh he knew like most of us when that
next wave hit in the 18 19 20. I was I
was following it probably in 17 18. yeah
um you know just really through my dad
so I'll give him some credit for that
and his passion for him became my
passion for it yeah I saw a lot of his
closest relationships came from from The
Hobby and from collecting and you know
he would always say to me look there's
so much opportunity here you know
there's it's such a legacy model the
business models the technology it felt
very archaic and when I when I went to
17's I think Cleveland or maybe I think
it was 17 or 18. the Cleveland
show
I was like whoa this is first of all
it's the best because that's how I
started my career and like it was the
best I just could smell it but I knew I
mean compared to what we're going to see
next week in Chicago it's like two
different shows I remember when I first
got into collector was coming from
Finance uh which obviously has a cache
reflectables at the time in 2019.
I remember telling people I'm leaving
Finance going to Collectibles they
looked at me like I had three heads yeah
and now just to show how how much the
industry has come when you say
Collectibles there's a cool Factor there
you know there's a they're interested
like that's awesome yes and I think
people are getting it I think the story
what was your favorite card as a kid
Jeter foil
crazy car that was literally just as I
got out I got out in 93.
and that like I really wish I was around
for one more year because I was like
hardcore 86 to 93. that's such a special
card yeah that's an awesome card I do
have one I've got an LT rookie card
which is awesome
um but you know again I didn't always
collect the most valuable I collecting
things that I like so yeah I Brian Lee's
rookie cards I have LJ rookie cards just
you know things that you know kind of
remind me of my childhood and things
that I love
as a kid though it was the foil or now
I'm actually asked wondering Isaac do
you remember I do I do remember I mean I
was six years old at the time but I
remember seeing that more and more
around and just being like I love Derek
Jeter I emulated Derek Jeter my batting
is dancing little league was Derek so I
remember that yeah the Derek Jeter car
he's gonna be at the national he's gonna
be the national
okay good what what do you think is most
interesting right now in the trading
card card part like what's your like as
an expert or at least you've been in it
expert's tough to throw at someone but
like as someone who's in it
and I you're very much focusing on your
business so it's not like you're
following like the auctions every hour
on the hour but you're in it
so because a lot of people have been in
it are coming like it's funny I feel
like a lot of people that were hot in 18
19 20 are starting to come back in a
little bit right now I can I could just
smell the waves again uh this is a
microwave compared to 18 and 19 but it's
some of the people that were out of it
for the last two years are starting to
come back who were in it in 18 19 20.
what's going on like what's what's like
interesting business fodder or consumer
Behavior fodder in trading cards right
now from one man's point of view I could
I could go on and on about this topic
for sure uh there's there's so much I
mean I kind of look at this as a tale of
two markets right there's the pricing
market and then there's the activity
market and I think when you look at the
pricing Market obviously you have this
big you know sort of rise in covid a lot
of those values have come have come down
but you know you still if you zoom out
from just you know 2022 to now you know
some of the most iconic cards are still
doing unbelievably right you look at the
Michael Jordan Fleer 8610 that was a
forty thousand dollar card right when
covet hit now 150 160 Grand that's a 4X
in four years that's an unbelievable
return look at the mantle 52 tops in an
eight right pre-cover that was 400 Grand
now it's 1 million 1.2 1.3 in that range
that's a great return right so and the
iconic stuff iconic is doing great you
know you you collect vintage basketball
I know so 69 70 tops I mean those are
putting up record numbers wagoners are
putting up numbers memorabilia is really
caught on not trading cards but
memorabilia is as absolutely exploded
um but you know you do have do you like
memorabilia I love memories you know
this about me reps I struggle with it I
don't know why I just don't love it
but from a business from an asset class
up it's very clear there's one of them
there's three of them there's five of
them like the the supply and demand is
very clear when I first got back home
why I don't like like I feel like
they're they're big I feel like this is
where nfts is going to do me a favor
like a big ass Jersey I'd rather if I
can set it to a mercile exchange and I'm
trading you know the nft similar to what
you're doing and like you're making it
easier for me to listen like you know
like that's what people want it's bulky
the the weirdest thing that I saw when I
came back to the market was uh the
pricing of memorabilia versus these kind
of patch cards made zero sense you know
you could you could buy a car that has a
little slice of a patch from Steph Curry
which may or may not have ever been used
in a game you know I don't know the
exactly but hundreds of thousands of
dollars you could buy the actual Jersey
that Steph Curry wore in a game photo
match so everyone knows it's real and it
was 20 30 grand that to me was like a
market
um
has started to close
on the activity side activity is really
strong I know right activity is really
good you know you like we're about to go
to the National there's a hundred
thousand people uh every show that
they've put on has been gangbusters
people are loving this stuff they're
clamoring for it they want more of it
Fanatics is coming in obviously and you
know essentially gobbled up all the
licenses they've incentivized all the
leagues and the players to now start
caring about this industry you know one
one thing that I always look at
long term in a real way I agree I mean
you know when you think about how many
collectors there are data is not amazing
but there's something like a million
people who identify as a collector
of 2 billion sports fans give or take a
million out of two billion that's a tiny
percentage look at you know fantasy
sports or Sports gambling uh you know
there's something like 20 to 25 of
sports fans you know participate in
sports gambling or fantasy sports
friction brother friction it's all
friction this is why what you're doing
caught our attention we are eliminating
friction which I think has you know as
really big is really big potential and
so you know I see you know when you hear
big numbers right now 10x 100x hobby
when you put those numbers in context
versus other ways to sort of participate
in sports it feels very achievable to me
so I'm incredibly bullish on this
industry I think it has a big Runway and
I'm very encouraged by the fact that
even the prices have come down activity
has stayed really strong and by the way
like like I had a laughed at my dad the
other day it was like complaining that
winetext.com please sign up winetext.com
that wine tax is not doing the numbers
that did during covid and I'm like Dad
nobody was allowed to go to a bar
or a store or like every single human
was home
and you had a monopoly as a category
internet people that could sell wine and
send it to your house like do you know
how much wine is going to be drank today
in America at bars and restaurants like
outrageous amounts that was all at home
and so like look the entertainment value
of what was going on with trading cards
during that time was like it was fun
like I was on eBay every minute on the
minute like there's other things I'm at
the airport today like like I'm doing
this with you in my office today like
it's just different but to your point
if you take that blip out of the
equation
the the data is very clear of what's
Happening Here and I think you're one
million two billion thing is
uncomfortably real and I'll add another
variable you have an entire generation
of 12 13 14 year olds that think of
themselves as entrepreneurs in a way
that even you at such a young age it
wasn't as common at 12 and 13 to think
that way you might have thought you
wanted to be in business but like you
take on entrepreneurship ambition at
youth along with how many collectors
have how many sports fans haven't
converted because fantasy and betting
has no friction what am I going to buy a
box open it slab it grade it go to a
show I'm not doing that [__] this is
where what is starting to happen of the
stack of the elimination of friction
both through the technology through the
players you know
the Natick spot pwcc yep like you know
like these things are going to start
colliding into each other and make it
very easy for someone like me who also
one of the reasons I don't want to sell
even though I have rips and like I can
like it's because just a lot of [__]
friction and I'm excited about what you
guys and other people in the space are
doing yeah one one thing too just you
know I think one of the byproducts of
covid even the prices have come down
from it a lot of big companies have come
into this market now I keep hearing new
companies that are massive Fortune 500
companies that are getting you know into
this hobby Blackstone Amazon DraftKings
Tick Tock the list could go on and on
and on fnatics obviously you know even
hedge funders Stevie Co and Dan Sondheim
big big names are getting big into this
Market one of the stats that I want to
point out too just in terms of kind of
the selling inefficiency and selling
friction this Market there were 10 times
more buyers than sellers of Collectibles
10 times and there's probably a lot of
good reasons for that but one that I
think strongly is that it is so
frictionful there's so much friction you
mean going to Chicago and shipping all
your stuff and setting up exactly yeah I
couldn't agree with you more and as
great as eBay is like like because by
the way that created an incredible thing
because I was selling cards pre if I if
eBay was around if this Market existed
when I was 15 years old I would have
never graduated high school
no shot in [__] hell put the flag in
the ground I'll show you my [__]
[__] report card it's somewhere here
zero chance
so to your point like I can't even
imagine what you and others are going to
be doing over the next couple years to
make it even less friction
yeah my just to give everybody context
what we're really going I think at least
where I'm going do you know how hard it
was to buy a piece of a company in
1875. I know that may seem like a long
time ago it's really not there used to
not be stocks to come like I can
literally hit a button in two seconds
right now and own .0003 of of a company
like that didn't exist and I think just
the friction well we've said it 10 times
but I think it really sums up why Adam
and I are excited about the company what
you're doing and what other people are
doing this move to the elimination of
friction including web three you know I
think the nft stuff is gonna be a factor
like
um
it's gonna be [__] rad all right we
got a couple more minutes here I want to
make sure
that was there anything we didn't touch
on anything you wanted to touch on in
our time here no welcome I think you
know if when people see the product and
they see how easy it is to get items in
to manage your whole collection you
could do thousands of items it takes a
minute to get your entire collection
beautifully displayed categorize all
that stuff when you link your accounts
and you click one button and now you see
the items are blasted out on 10
different marketplaces there actually is
real magic to that and it's unbelievable
what you know our team's been able to
create I think it's going to make you
know the entire selling journey and just
the managing Journey uh so much easier
and so we're incredibly excited well
listen we're excited to see you at the
national we'll be we'll maybe we'll film
some interactions unless Dustin dies
from this cough
um you know he'll be there we'll film it
um yes thank you go ahead reps let's do
that this is a good way to close I love
you good job reps okay good show me so
I'm with the product right now with the
product so look I think right off the
top like the interface like for
everyone's listening now who's like
accustomed to like web 2 interface and
like modern stuff like this is kind of
what we snipped out like look Google
Docs is great and all but like [__] like
like managing this in a much easier way
it's very clear to me like how this is
structured
this is a blank slate yeah it says let's
get started out on Easter collection we
just sent a bunch of cards to grading
for cgc for the national yep big shout
out cgc nice I like your new slabs by
the way I like the black so do I this is
a cold you agree this is a [__]
interesting thing they are very
technologically savvy they're incredibly
responsive for more dealings with them
and they have an unbelievable slab yeah
yeah and they have completely dominated
non-sports I obviously got very very
serious because even before V friends is
Rip stoves I like to buy a lot of weird
[__] non-sports because I love Nostalgia
He-Man and Spider-Man and 1960 whatever
Donruss like Marvel 60 what is it 60s
I'm already getting rusty 60 61 is Fleer
basketball 67 Donruss 66 Donruss I think
it's 66 genres
okay anyway but like cgc is like a
little bit of a sleeper play like now
they're getting serious about sports
that's one of the weird like look PSA is
a beast I'm a big fan of SGC you know I
think Beckett is every like be back to J
you know Mr Beckett like Beckett has so
much Heritage so much Heritage and I I
have a lot of empathy for them because
they're great guys and gals too I'm like
I feel like they've they've got to like
tighten like they got a lot going on
with their grading system and they've
got to figure that out a little bit but
like I think it's such a healthy Market
with like Nat is like a [__] so like
I sleep at night knowing PSA is always
going to do the right things the cgc
stuff has really got my attention of how
much especially because with be friends
I feel like I want to go more Magic the
Gathering more Pokemon so I actually
want it to be a predominant cgc winner
Then I then me and rips looked at the
data they're like very conservative on
their grading which I think long term
always plays out that people like that
value so it's interesting to see you
have a from your perspective a good look
on them as well I agree I agree go ahead
this is literally a download of your
grading order okay of the grading order
from the submission
which everyone gets when they do all
this stuff so for all the graders that's
makes sense so you can drive you can
literally just drag this I'll do it you
can do it but if you so this was a
monster this was a monster
um this was
that was very smart of you guys so
you're saying this literally the [__]
slab submission Drag and Drop Like drag
and drop who the [__] wouldn't do it all
in one if you want to do serial numbers
and drag and drop and files you can do
you can do it all in one screen
yeah this is gonna once people
understand this they're gonna
map field
no sync
so this is three three hundred cards
we're doing 279 cards
one percent is done three percent four
percent's done five percent's done this
must be very compelling podcast nine
percent is done 13 is done but no no I
mean this is bananas
so right so for everyone who's like a
little more sophisticated I know there's
not one-on-one people I know there's a
lot of people that are like into Tech
they'll probably check this out people
just starting especially because the
befriends cards for the more
sophisticated who've submitted for
grading and you know you get your report
no [__] the downloaded CSV dragged
into an interface I'm now at 72 we're
probably well under a minute at this
point like the thought that I just I'm
about to have 279 cards in a CRM that
looks good
it's done it's done all right click
click refresh page click refresh
I'm just gonna do play-by-play for
everybody because I know this is
predominantly audio consumption
but we're also on very bad Wi-Fi here at
vaynermedia we should really address
that
I guess that's my fault so I'll try it
holy [__] no [__] okay and so all right
so what I'm looking at is a very good
visual like the way you would like it if
you're a web two oh person like it's got
the card all imagery in there and then I
can fill in item cost tax shipping so
you can you can fill that in yourself or
you can upload a spreadsheet that has
that data already there right because a
lot of people have already do it that
way right exactly right right right
right right right you can sort that's
how you can have it and you should just
upload your accelerator
can sort that you can filter
no really we were hiding on everything
no but this is this is [__] really
nice
when they use like the Vintage stuff
they don't have the images ready you
kind of have to upload them but like all
the modern stuff this is literally took
two seconds and then selfishly this is
[__] right me knowing both of you
guys for a while I I did when you
started talking about what years things
come from I pulled up like the top 15
like iconic rookie cards and I wanted to
quiz you guys well I can see who okay go
ahead what do you got all right try it
go ahead let's go into something I'm
rusty though I forgot 66 Donruss Marvel
just now so I'm not very confident but
this should be compelling
so what is the what is the quiz
literally I was like you're talking 93
SP okay go ahead so what are you gonna
do hold like some cards from your
collection
and some cards like that top 20 most
influential rookie cards of all time
like who knows I understand I don't care
about any of that I just want to be
Nazareth what is the game right now
you need okay fair enough all right look
I would say it's your
collections ready
I love this ready for this got some home
court advantage here if you like your
job I refuse for you to mention any card
is it my Personal Collection use ones
that are not in my personal collection
oh
preferably saying I do not believe I
have an advantage of owning something
that every is an iconic card
let's just play real quick by the way on
the record I'm extremely Rusty like are
we gonna buzz in here yeah okay
20 no uh yeah 22 2001. correct 2001.
notice I wasn't even in that that was my
dark era I was building I want to give a
shout out to my dad Sasha completely
[__] me in this moment because it made
me work tirelessly from 1998. I thought
I thought we were gonna start off with
like a vintage like 61 Fleer I was
literally 16. I was thrown off by the
2000s keep doing what you're doing I
love that I didn't even have a guess
that's how much I don't give a [__]
about Albert pools or that card
um Donruss Don Mattingly 87 nope no 84
84 84 84 84. I still think if you go to
I think if you go go to the film I said
84 100th of a second earlier by the way
second wrong guess by the way I'm I'm
optimizing for time not after here I'm
just trying to win
oh uh 55. no
um
[__] I have the car too uh
Unitus is
57 oh we're close
should cut this out two years ago would
have gotten all these in one second
besides Pujols me too so Rusty
shadowless first edition Charizard
I'm not I'm not a Charizard guy what yes
yeah I got it is that 90 I'm gonna say
yeah it's six in the 90s 99 99 yeah top
speed Maravich pistol three
69 nope no no no keep this segment
Pistol Pete is not that it's later than
69.70 here
Pistol Pete is what 70
one looks like that 72. Pistol Pete is
1970. 70. OPG Wayne Gretzky oh 79 79
that's right good
oh you're right Jesus Christ I thought
Super Bowl good job
tops Hank Aaron 54.
I know I know vintage I know vintage
magic
80. 79.80 yeah you got that three more
tops Chrome Tim Duncan
97. very good
National Treasures Steph Curry 2009.
last one
football gym
when I tell you I needed
the selfish because I just got my ass
kicked and my brother am I able to give
my my dad a quick shout out here please
so my dad has uh a great collection I'm
sure my mom will hate me for saying this
but one of his coolest pieces in his
collection is a type one vintage
photograph of that iconic Jim Brown
rookie card he will be at the national
so and I think he's going to have it on
display it's an awesome awesome piece
I've seen it many times and it's
incredible as
I'm really upset with you right now
because you beat my face and I'm not
happy about it I didn't realize how
Rusty I was I'm excited to get like I
wish we really did this after the
national I feel like I would have had a
better chance but congrats excited look
forward to seeing you there thank you
continue success I appreciate let's talk
more I really I really like what you
guys are up to everybody listening you
should definitely give it a roll I think
a lot of you can be impressed because I
do think the industry has got big shout
out to the industry tons of great [__]
lots of stuff what not there's just so
many things I'm proud of that so many
people have done but a long way to go of
opportunity not mad anybody we've made a
lot of strides the last four or five
years uh this is a good move in the
right direction so keep up the good work
awesome buddy thanks so much appreciate
it
thank you
[Music]